I also cannot show web bashing Athena
I'm a light Bible and these or shocking
questions and these are my let's go pen
guys are looking at all why does he look
like Sean hey Claire do you think it
looks like Sean my tour manager selfie
look he didn't see me like this
weasel Brava she was sweat fun she just
hot mrs. Mike I know people tend to
sweat like this when I'm around you're
pink in its own language we've got from
the heart I'll be now that's after this
is all your music in this Mike oh okay
who is the most famous person in your
context ah this is animal cruelty
oh my good eye let's go wow you like
this here feeling a bit freaky in it I
mean sometimes I get what be starstruck
no I've never been so that's all never
know I felt a bit tingly when I saw the
answer would you see her in the club it
was what's not gonna decreed again
Michael B Jordan yeah it was his
birthday party
I'm p.m. takers and jay-z sat right
across from me and now just like like
I'm Jacob usually favorite artists
Oh guys you'd hope the chair oh whoa I
broke you don't go cheap IKEA chairs
I'm gonna fix it don't worry what where
we know you deserve the chair like this
anyway - beginning what is the most
embarrassing - I shouldn't have been a
famous person I've never had an
embarrassing direction at all know
everyone's been super cool she met
someone any like properly before - no no
I didn't find if I did they wouldn't
notice me
oh jesus not faze me who would you most
want to collab with I like the weekend
yeah I love the weekend appointments
those points to like being there
why something you hate that everyone
else loves peanuts peanuts I'm allergic
to peanuts what's the first thing you do
when conversation first thing I do when
I come off stage is eat ice why I love
our plain-jane eyes have you ever stolen
something yeah of course everyone's
felon come on sweets from the
supermarket I've noticed all in my life
he's lying why use your guilty pleasure
[Music]
all the questions I have all I feels
good you know
hello freakily
[Laughter]
you
you